we all know kraft heinz as the legacy
food brand in supermarkets from their
various condiments to their cheese and
ready-made meals craft heinz is one of
the biggest names in food yet despite
their dominant status amongst the
grocery isles kraft heinz isn't actually
doing that well
their last several quarters have been
hit or miss in terms of profit they were
recently exposed for an accounting
scandal and their stock is down over 50
percent from their 2017 highs you would
think that the top investors would stay
miles away from this company but
ironically one of the biggest investors
in kraft heinz is actually warren
buffett and as you would guess kraft
heinz has been one of buffett's worst
investments of all time
buffett has admitted that he did overpay
for the craft portion of the business
but he has no plans of selling
actually what i said was we paid too
much for hines
i mean craft i'm sorry
it should be noted though that buffett
owns 26 percent of kraft heinz so he
really has no easy way out in terms of
selling that large of a stake so his
decision to hold may have more to do
with the lack of liquidity than an
optimistic outlook for kraft heinz this
brings up the question what even
happened to kraft heinz and can they
actually recover like buffett is hoping
taking a look back at the history of
craft heinz the company's story actually
dates back over 100 years to 1876 to a
man named henry john heinz henry was
born to german immigrants and was
determined to achieve the american dream
so at age 33 he began a small food
business with his cousin and brother and
just like today heinz was basically
synonymous with ketchup in the late
1800s given that this was their first
product while the company performed well
under henry's leadership it never became
a food behemoth or anything it wasn't
until henry's son howard took over and
the great depression hit the heinz
really took off you see when money was
extremely tight heinz ready to eat meals
and cheap condiments were an
indispensable part of the average
american's diet
and by the time america recovered from
the great depression heinz had become a
staple amongst grocery stores and it was
just a matter of scaling and maintaining
their dominance in terms of craft side
of the business their history also dates
back 100 years to 1909. like heinz kraft
was also a family business started by a
canadian immigrant james ellcraft and
his brother started off as door-to-door
chief salesmen not only were they good
salesmen but they were also phenomenal
cheese producers in 1916 they figured
out a new method to pasteurize cheese
that gave their cheeses significantly
longer shelf life they went ahead and
patented this technique which gave them
an edge over the competition but when
they received an acquisition offer that
was too good to refuse they went ahead
and sold their company to national dairy
products corporation in 1930. the craft
brand was mainly just as subsidiary for
the next 39 years until national dairy
decided to revive the brand by renaming
the parent company graphical corporation
in 1969 19 years after this in 1988
general mills would acquire the craft
brand and they would hold on to it for
the next 19 years
it was until 2007 that general mill
started to sell off craft on the public
markets which finally made it an
independent company once again eight
years later in 2015 the boards of both
craft and heinz approved a merger in an
attempt to create a food giant but they
ended up creating a food disaster so
what went wrong
likely one of the biggest factors
holding back kraft tines is the boom of
super retailers like walmart sam's club
and costco as these guys grow larger
they have started to directly compete
with suppliers
for example walmart has great value
sam's club has members mark and costco
has kirkland if you're not familiar with
these brands they're comparable to
generic brand medicine they basically go
out and copy all of the most popular
products within their stores and given
that such retailers have insane
economies of scale and in-house
production capacity they can usually
offer the same products for
substantially less for instance here's
the official oreos and great values
oreos side by side while these are
basically the same product great values
offerings are almost half the cost a
19.1 ounce packet of oreos clocks in at
3.98
while a 19.1 ounce packet of great value
oreos cost 2.08 cents now of course many
people including myself will always just
go with the legacy brand but a good
portion of people won't really care
not only does this drive revenue away
from legacy food brands but it forces
these brands to be more competitive with
price which ranks their profit margins
now this is great news for consumers but
for name brands who already have meager
profit margins such competition can
easily push them into unprofitability
fortunately craft heinz themselves have
pretty large operations meaning that
they can put up a good fight against
generic brands but with that being said
such competition has shrunk the net
margins down to the single digits aside
from diminishing margins the truth is
that craft heinz doesn't actually have
that much room to grow in the first
place while the company has made several
acquisitions to try to continue growth
this hasn't exactly been successful at
the end of the day kraft and heinz are
still only known for the two products
that they were founded on cheese and
ketchup and the problem is that they've
basically reached market saturation
within these sectors after all their
products are already dirt cheap and
available everywhere in the us so anyone
who wants these products can easily get
them considering this i don't think
you'd be surprised to hear that their
revenue has flatlined at 25 to 26
billion dollars for the past six years
the revenue also basically has zero
volatility their best and worst 12-month
periods within the past six years are
within seven percent of each other and
while this may be great for stability
it's absolutely garbage for growth
now you might be thinking it with the
introduction of in-house generic brands
it's basically impossible to break into
the food industry and while this is
partially true given that the food
industry is extremely brutal and cut
throat one sector of the industry has
been growing rapidly and that's
healthier options usually within any
market you have the bougie sector with
cars you have mercedes and audi with
smartphones you have apple and samsung
and with food you have organic options
and whole foods while this portion of
the market is substantially more
profitable the size of this market is
generally much smaller if you want to go
the biggest business possible it's
usually better to target the rest of the
market and that's exactly what craft and
heinz have been doing for over a hundred
years but the problem is that this
strategy only works up until a certain
point once you're under a price point
which consumers deem fair they start to
make their buying decisions based on
other factors like health now this isn't
to say that the average person is all of
a sudden strictly buying organic foods
from whole foods but the average person
has trended towards buying foods with
less preservatives less processing and
more natural ingredients and craft
heinz's offerings are basically the
antithesis to this trend if anything
their products have historically become
more processed as they try to keep up
with the prices of generic brands over
the past few years they have shifted
their focus onto the health trend for
example their newer mac and cheese boxes
probably state that they have no
artificial preservatives no artificial
flavors and no artificial dyes however
this hasn't been all that successful
first of all craft heinz was late to
this trend which gave consumers ample
time to find alternatives and secondly
craft heinz can't just erase their
association with processed foods which
has been ingrained in consumers minds
for literally a century with a simple
marketing campaign likely the best
option for kraft heinz was acquiring
up-and-coming brands that weren't held
back by the association but they've
screwed this up pretty badly as well
the main acquisition that didn't
particularly help the company was the
merger of craft and heinz itself not
only did heinz likely overpay for craft
like warren buffett suggested but there
was really no reason to complete the
merger in the first place the idea was
that craft and heinz could share
manufacturing facilities and marketing
efforts in order to lower costs and
reach an even larger audience
but as we just discussed lower prices
aren't exactly what consumers even want
so all this merger did was locking craft
heinz on a cost reduction journey that
didn't even need to take place and to
make things worse given how
interconnected the two companies are now
it's even harder for them to switch pads
compared to if they were just
independent companies also it's not just
me who thinks this acquisition was not
the best craft heinz themselves admit
that this was a poor merger which is
evident in how they wrote off craft and
oscar mayor as a 15 billion loss this
write-off was followed by a dividend
reduction of 36 percent and just when
you think things can't get worse craft
also announced that they were under
investigation by the sec for their
accounting practices unfortunately this
investigation would result in evidence
that kraft heinz was indeed engaging in
accounting misconduct between 2015 and
2018 kraft had recognized unearned
discounts from suppliers and maintained
false and misleading supplier contracts
this allowed them to understate their
expenses and overstate their profit by
the end of the investigation kraft had
to correct a total of 208 million
dollars worth of bogus cost savings and
they refined a total of 62 million
dollars during such tough times you
would hope that the leadership of the
company was strong and had a game plan
but this wasn't the case either in april
of 2019 the ceo bernard he's left the
company at the peak of their troubles it
should also be mentioned that his time
as ceo wasn't that great either his
legacy at kraft is literally firing
thousands of employees in an effort to
cut costs so clearly craft heinz hasn't
been doing that great internally or
externally for several years
despite all these shortfalls warren
buffett still believed that kraft and
heinz are wonderful businesses and that
their main mistake was simply overpaying
for craft with that being said though
the only reason he still has a position
in the company is because it's not easy
to get out buffet said quote we can't as
a practical matter move around tens of
billions of dollars that easily but
beyond that i mean if we're working with
a million dollars or 10 million dollars
would i have a position in it no
and i think this tells us everything we
need to know about what buffett really
thinks about the future of the company
he wouldn't invest in it right now but
since he already has a position he's
hoping to see it through which is quite
possible it's been some time since the
merger happened and the pandemic started
which has allowed kraft heinz to regain
profitability their profits are still
low compared to what they used to be
which is leading to a high p e ratio of
67 but as their profits continue to
recover this number should only go down
also craft heinz may be able to bump up
their dividend again which could attract
a lot more investors all these factors
could help krafthein stock return to
their all-time highs and potentially
even beat their highs but given all of
the underlying issues that we've
discussed so far i think kraft heinz
will have a difficult time growing much
further than that but that's just what i
think why do you guys think craft heinz
is performing so poorly comment that
down below
also drop a like if you've ever had
their ketchup or their mac and cheese
and of course consider checking out our
international channels to watch our
videos in other languages and consider
subscribing to see more questions
logically answered but until then i'm
hari and i'll see you guys on the next
one
[Music]